foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'm pers Morgan I'm
censored tonight freedom and free speech
from the shocking abandonment of Afghan
women to the Taliban to Donald Trump's
possible Twitter comeback and the death
of Comedy I'll discuss that with the new
Superstar of U.S late night television
but first it's my orwellian free speech
brain dump
foreign
knew a thing or two about Free Speech
you could fill a book with sensible
things you had to say about it this
quote especially resonates today
at any given moment there is an
Orthodoxy he wrote a body of ideas of
which it's assumed that all right
thinking people will accept without
question it's not exactly forbidden to
say this that or the other but it's not
done to say it well incredibly things
have got a great deal worse since Orwell
wrote that because it is indeed not
forbidden to say this that or the other
and the Orthodoxy today is the Draconian
illiberal world view stamped on public
life a woke fundamentalists this cancel
culture mob said all the rules tramping
over our rights to free speech in the
process and anyone who doesn't conform
is instantly slam silenced and shamed
and much of it is of course politically
motivated that's why former president
Trump is barred from Twitter even though
74 million people voted for him in a
democratic election but Vladimir Putin
the supreme leader of Iran and the
Taliban are all still free to tweet this
is obviously utterly ridiculous now the
billionaire Maverick in free speech
absolutist Elon Musk is about to buy
Twitter says that the ban is morally
wrong and he will reverse it and he's
been supported by Jack Dorsey one of the
founders of Twitter Trump told me he
doesn't actually want to return to
Twitter even if he's allowed to but I
reckon he'll change his mind about that
and the point is it should be his
decision
liberals have reacted with an inferno of
rage and panic as they always do to
everything ever since muss said he'd
restore free speech and shunt to the
platform London mayor said he can't
today blame Trump for a massive Spike
and abuse he got online but even he says
he's open to Trump returning but he
qualified it by adding let's wait and
see if Donald Trump has learned his
lesson if it's the case I think that's
all well and good if he breaks the rules
there need to be consequences well
that's fine words but there's the number
of the problem who decides what those
rules are which are to be broken all
racist abuse is wrong and so is any
incitement to violence but both of those
things are already illegal Free Speech
doesn't mean you can break the law nor
does it mean you have to continue
listening to somebody who's spewing
something vile that you don't like
to illustrate that Sports presenter Eli
Barber has written today about how she
dealt with completely unacceptable
homophobic and racist comments made
during an Argentina's speech at a
Scottish sports awards at the weekend
she didn't demand the speaker be
canceled but she did exercise her right
to walk out and she exercised her right
to free speech to call it out on Twitter
and that was right
believe me and this may shock you people
do say nasty things about me all the
time on the internet I don't want to
cancel them but I do sometimes block
them or call them utter morons that too
is an exercising of my right to free
speech
foreign one of the biggest problems with
Twitter is that many people on it don't
seem to have any sense of humor my fiery
interview with the taliban's official
spokesman last night got everyone
talking and Twitter of course whipped
itself into a frothy lather of Rage
about them in fact I was even doing it
one woman named Laura treated comedian
Ricky Gervais always a bad idea to say
what do you think about Piers Morgan
into the metallic man tonight and she
added the hashtag disgusting
or Gervais replied like this I've lost
all respect for them foreign
laughter so that any wokies watching
realize he was joking
but not everyone knew this so you mean
you've had respect for them was one
reply to Gervais I thought you claimed
to be an advocate for free speech said
another now you're backtracking on
people that's because they want to air
an opinion you don't like
incredibly even the Daily Mirror a
national newspaper I used to run failed
to get the joke
Ricky Gervais slams Piers Morgan the
disgusting Taliban interview it raged
no he didn't no he wasn't
he was joking obviously but obviously
not
otherwise he would have got the joke it
took another British comedian David
bedeel to point out the bleeding obvious
this is a great joke he tweeted that's
it that was it it was a funny joke
that was off the back of an incredibly
serious sobering subject but we must
never let serious things in the world
made me lose our sense of humor
unfortunately jokes are increasingly an
endangered species in today's miserable
Mr mortar of a world were being mortally
offended and outraged is very much in
fashion the joyless won't Brigade are so
desperate to feel aggrieved
affronted
and appalled
twitch I remind them all of the advice
from the late great Cricket genius Shane
Warne
and in this politically correct day and
age we've just got to be a little bit
careful but sometimes just say get stuff
to the fun police
I mean seriously just tell them to get
stuffed
nobody puts always better and the man
who got me into all this mess last night
Mr Gervais
there's going to be a bit of that
throughout the show see if you can spot
it okay now that's when I say summer I
don't really mean the comic effect and
you as an audience you laugh at the
wrong thing because you know what the
right thing is it's a way of satirizing
attitudes not our first joke I use the
old-fashioned sexist Trope that women
aren't funny now in real life I know
there are loads of funny women like um
foreign
even as that clip ends I know there are
people tweeting me incensed wokies who
don't get the joke well perhaps they do
get it but pretend not to so they can
virtually signal their mock outrage it
and they are exhausting
well as his tiresome woke his whale
about Trump being unbanned from Twitter
and halfwood excuses for journalists
failed the irony test and would have
failed my employment test if I was still
at the mirror real free speech Champions
are putting their lives on the line for
the truth every single day Palestinian
reporter Shareen Abu aklay was shot and
killed today while covering an Israeli
raid in the West Bank the Al Jazeera
correspondent is also a U.S citizen was
hugely respected she's reported for
decades on flashpoints in Israel and
Palestine bravely Crossing between both
sides report uncomfortable truths about
a complex and emotive conflict she was
wearing a press badge
journalists like Shireen are the reason
why we understand the world George
Orwell himself wrote vividly about the
Spanish Civil War a free press is the
reason we know that Putin is a genocidal
war criminal while Millions have
brainwashed Russians in a country where
journalists get murdered for their job I
think he's saving Ukraine from Nazis
several journalists have already been
killed in Ukraine covering the war many
others are out there right now risking
their lives to bring us that truth
now you might be tempted to think that a
free press can be taken for granted in
2022 but it can't the facts show it's in
Decline as time we began fighting much
harder for it more and more countries
are gagging reporters many years of
pandemic as an excuse to muzzle
journalists on the bogus pretext of
protecting public health and according
to UNESCO a staggering 85 percent of the
world's population lives in a place
where press Freedom has been restricted
in the last five years
and ironically by their own measure the
last time press Freedom plummeted to
these depths was 1984 the very title of
George Orwell's iconic novel
when you speak was of course the name of
a dystopian language in George Orwell's
1984. it was a controlled and contorted
vocabulary designed to limit people's
ability to think for themselves well
besides being a free speech Champion
almost had a big imagination but I doubt
even he would have believed that
newspeakers now being imposed on British
doctors and nurses
first maternity Services were ordered to
use gender-inclusive terms like chest
feeding for new mothers to avoid
upsetting trans patients
to which I say well what about the upset
calls to women who want to identify as
women and be called women and mothers
and who want to be told they're
breastfeeding what are their rights
well now NHS bosses are being lectured
on the danger of microaggressions which
is one of my least favorite words in the
whole English language apparently these
can be worse than overt acts of hate and
could cause PTSD post-traumatic stress
disorder what
what does that even mean
people have literally had to deal every
day with patients suffering very real
PTSD from life-threatening illness or
terrible injuries I've now got to watch
their words in case it sends perfectly
healthy people into a spiral of trauma
when did we get so pathetic
why did we get so pathetic
I grew up in a world where the usual
advice offered to anyone who overreacted
to her for words with sticks and stones
may break my bones but words will never
hurt me
I kind of miss that world
well coming up how do we save Afghan
women from the Taliban walls should
Trump be allowed to tweet again China's
zero covered Nightmare and one of the
funniest men in America Greg Gutfeld is
live all coming up all uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
regime tightens his grip over the people
of Afghanistan it's the women who are
suffering catastrophically they're
treated like chattels a human rights
have been taken away they're forced to
wear full face coverings and if they
don't their male Guardians face
imprisonment last night nonsense if I
interviewed Taliban spokesperson suhail
Shaheen and challenged him on this Mr
Shaheen of course denied it was
happening
99 of the up on women they are observing
hijab voluntarily
so they consider it a dignity a
safeguard for uh their modesty
I asked about teenage girls are still
being banned from going to school
we have never said they are banned girls
have the right to have access to
education as boys yeah except we're not
allowed to go to school so that's a
nonsense I then asked him if his own
daughters went to school
of course yeah yeah of course and really
of course they do because you're in
Delaware and they can go to school right
yeah yeah they are observing hijab they
are observing any hijab and so well that
means we have not denied
of course one rule for his daughters
another rule for everybody else's
daughters in Afghanistan but joining me
now a former U.S ambassador to the
United Nations political consultant John
Bolton and chief foreign correspondent
for the Sunday Times Christina Lan who's
in Ukraine well welcome to both of you
Christina let me start with you because
you spent so much time in Afghanistan uh
interviewing the spokesman for the
Taliban was pretty dispiriting last
night because I felt like he was
spinning a completely bogus narrative
about what is going on there and it
seems pretty clear to journalists who
are on the ground that women are being
taken right back to the medieval dark
ages of the previous Taliban rule
yeah it is very dispiriting it's like
been one restriction after another
particularly in the last few months um
so women can't travel on their own women
are not supposed to go out their house
on their own
um we thought that girls were going to
be able to go back to high school in
March and then they went that day and
was sent straight back home uh many of
them in floods of Tears so it's been
absolutely terrible for women and girls
since the Taliban took over and all of
the hope at the beginning that this was
a sort of different kind of Taliban
somehow
um I'm afraid now really doesn't look
like that and this latest restriction of
the hijab and um in particular
recommending that they should wear the
book or is really the last nail in the
coffin I think yeah I mean John Bolton
many people would say that the uh
American sudden overnight withdrawal
from Afghanistan done basically handed
the whole country back to the Taliban
very quickly allowed them to now
suppress women all over again and almost
certainly emboldened Vladimir Putin to
conclude that maybe Joe Biden wasn't up
for the fight anymore and that's why he
invaded Ukraine what what do you think
of that
well I don't think it was simply the
withdrawal last summer I think in the
Trump Administration critical mistakes
were made most particularly negotiating
only with the Taliban about a potential
U.S and and NATO withdrawal not bringing
in the government of Afghanistan and I
think president Trump was so eager to
get out of the country that he didn't
really care what he left behind so no
negotiations with the Taliban about
human rights or women's rights and no
participation of the legitimate
government of Afghanistan until the end
when they received the basically a done
deal from the U.S on the way out so I
think I think the entire process of
trying to cut a deal with the terrorist
organization was a mistake from start to
finish what you're seeing now tragically
I think was entirely predictable
yeah Christina you're now in Ukraine
um it's obviously horrendous what's
going on there
um but there are well there is a belief
by many people that the Ukraine
resistance is strong and that there is a
chance that Russia could actually lose
this what's your feeling on the ground
there
yeah I mean the Ukraine resistance has
been astonishing
um really humbling every body that you
meet is so United in Ukraine pretty much
and then trying to drive out the
Russians but I'm in the east at the
moment and which is where sort of second
offensive is is going on and that's a
little bit different I mean we know that
Russia was kind of humiliated in in
trying to to take Eve in the center of
the country and was driven back but but
here the the front line is much more
static it's sort of moving a few miles
back and forth and it you know looks
like it could that was near the front
line yesterday it looks like it could go
on for a very long time and John Bolton
what is your assessment of how America
and Joe Biden in particular have handled
the Ukraine crisis and what do you make
of the development today where Boris
Johnson's basically said to Finland and
Norway if any if you come under attack
from Russia we'll be there for you and
they're obviously lined up now to join
NATO what do you think of NATO in all
this and the and the way America has
handled it
well to start with uh Biden I I think uh
the the basic failure at work here is
the failure to deter the Russian
invasion to begin with I mean nobody can
be happy uh regardless of NATO's
performance or the Ukrainian military's
performance uh after the Russian
invasion takes place simply because
we've supplied weapons and ammunition to
the ukrainians or simply because we've
imposed uh sanctions on Russia that's
not a happy situation the objective here
should have been deter Russia from
invading in the first place and that
failed for a number of reasons the lack
of credibility of the administration the
lack of the gravity and threats involved
uh and I think Putin's misapprehension
of what he would find once he got inside
Ukraine but but all those failures now
that's that's good good for historical
debate the real question is do we have
staying power to continue this there
were press reports a few days ago the
president of Volkswagen for example San
it was time to negotiate a deal with the
Russians and you can you can uh count on
the Kremlin believing that that's uh
coming up that the West as a whole will
lose its resolve uh and that he will be
able to take uh the substantial
territory he's gained notwithstanding
the the Colossal failures of the Russian
military remember this war is still
being fought on Ukrainian territory
Ukraine is still being ground into dust
and Russian forces are still way ahead
of where they were the night of February
the 24th
Christina I don't want to let you go
without congratulating you because
tonight it was announced to you at the
Society of editors you you were you
received an outstanding contribution to
journalism Awards so congratulations on
a well-deserved award I followed you for
a long time you're an outstandingly
courageous journalist and we've touched
on today already that we saw another
journalist killed today uh over in uh
covering the israel-palestine conflict
we've seen journalists killed in the
Ukraine as well uh it's a dangerous time
to be a foreign correspondent isn't it
but I think it's a really important time
to be a foreign correspondent I mean
actually Ukraine I think in a time of
you know all lots of discussion of fake
news and all of this that actually shows
the importance of Journalism and being
there and bringing back the stories I
mean some of the atrocities that
um many of my colleagues have been
reporting of that the Russians have done
I think you know it's really it's
horrendous it's difficult for us to hear
far more difficult for the people to go
through it's difficult for people to
read about or listen to but it's really
important that we document those things
and bring to book the people that are
doing these horrendous things whether
it's you know
um raping killing
um you know blowing up schools and
hospitals people here say that the most
dangerous place to hide now is in a
school because the Russians keep um
bombing them absolutely disgusting well
congratulations on the well-deserved
keep up your great work out there we
need the truth and it's people like you
that bring it to us and thanks also to
you John Bolton appreciate you coming on
the show
thank you
well now one of my favorite sport stars
is tennis player Emma radicanu she came
from absolutely nowhere of course to
stand the world and win the US Open she
showed a remarkable strength and
resilience for a 19 year old but also a
very likable and engaging character but
she forgot the Golden Rule when it comes
to showing off your television skills in
a foreign language to an interviewer
never ask your friends to advise you on
what to say they will always do this to
you
last one is about your Italian did you
learn some words in these days few days
um
I did like
is that a bad word
oh my friend told me that one
what does it mean what does it mean uh I
will tell you later really at the end at
the end of the week
I'm afraid you had Emma and it was a
very bad word in Italian uh so
congratulations to your friend who
stitched you up like the proverbial
Kipper
well and since the next Elon Musk is
morally wrong for Donald Trump to be
banned from Twitter is he right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
what I'd eat on musk was going to
reinstate Donald Trump to Twitter I've
got to admit I smiled I've kind of
missed it it's been a bit boring without
him and his own particular brand of
raging Perma controversy and there were
wonderful moments like this
none of us will ever forget what we were
we read this and thought what the hell
is he talking about we still have no
idea what he was talking about
nobody was safe from Trump's tweets he
had a go at London mayor said he can't
calling him a terrible mayor and
foolishly nasty this was after Sadiq
Khan allowed a big gigantic grotesque
balloon to fly over Parliament Square
during Trump's State visit today Sadiq
Khan said this about the idea of trump
was coming back to Twitter
the amount of racial abuse I received
are the social media
increased by two thousand percent
2017 Trump's first year in the last
European Union president
once he's done from Twitter
I received the least ratio of use at any
time over five years
well shouldn't you be allowed back
joining me now is conservative radio
host Ben Ferguson I'm pretty glad to
visiting campaign at Gina Miller welcome
to both of you
um Ben I'll come to you in a moment
lovely to see you thank you for coming
to the to the thing Jack Dorsey uh has
defended uh Elon Musk saying Trump
should come back he said he does agree
but he had some got some exceptions he
said in terms of behavior spam Network
manipulation and legal Behavior but
generally he said permanent Bans are a
failure of ours and don't work and he
said that it was a business decision and
they shouldn't make business decisions
about freedom of speech I have to say I
agree with him because um you know one
of the things that Elon Musk said was
that um he is a free speech absolutist
well that means he's black and white and
actually life is Shades of Gray so
there's some there's quite worrying that
he said that and he's going to be if the
deal goes through in charge of Twitter
but I think it's um free speech is
different from inciting violence or
fueling hatred or you know the Integrity
of an electoral system but saying
someone you know abusing someone
disagreeing with them or being harsh on
them you have every right to say that
right I mean I thought he can't getting
racist abuse because Donald Trump uh
criticized him on Twitter I didn't see I
don't see how you can make that
connection well I thought it was a bit
serious because I didn't see Donald
Trump encouraging people to be racist
about Sadiq God he was criticizing him
he's got 80 million followers including
a lot of idiots clearly we thought it
was okay to racial abuse him Ben
Ferguson the argument against bringing
Donald Trump back is that he incited
violence on January the 6th at the
capital and that was why he got banned
that was a a reason Twitter had at the
time I've got to say that when you when
you think that Vladimir Putin the
Supreme Iran leader and the Taliban
Chiefs are all still on Twitter it seems
a ridiculous moment that the president
of the United States is not there
yeah it was it was their excuse they
were looking for an excuse to silence
what many would argue as the most
powerful man on Twitter at the time
Donald Trump and that was their excuse
they were waiting for an opportunity and
you notice within a couple of hours
everything had banned him right from
social media Facebook jumped on there
sites that allow you to sell Goods even
banned him because they hated Donald
Trump and if you look at Twitter and you
look at their big problem now it's even
when they say that he should come back
under certain guidelines those own
guidelines still don't apply to Vladimir
Putin to Isis leaders to Al Qaeda the
Ayatollah I mean the list goes on and on
and on of people you even had someone
last week that threatened Supreme Court
Justices by giving out their addresses
and say you will not feel safe until you
are dead in the ground and they didn't
even suspend that Twitter account so the
idea that Twitter is out there going oh
we're gonna we're gonna have Law and
Order here is absurd and they should
allow people to come back and if you
don't like what they say then fine you
as a user have the option to never look
at Donald Trump's tweets again I mean
that's the point I would say is that you
know with free speech people sometimes
get it wrong I think what free speech is
you know you don't have to listen to you
can block people on Twitter I do that a
lot if they're just really horrendously
abusive I think at the moment but this
whole conversation which is actually
shape lots of Shades of Gray is that um
we're looking at the medium not the
message because actually there are lots
of if you did that again if you spray
painted graffiti which incited violence
then that's illegal just because you're
doing it on social media it should be
the same rule so the rules that should
not be applied to the medium it's the
message
I think it wasn't a life band but I
think I would look at it and see that he
there were times when he incited hatred
and he did Fuel insurgents and he did
cause
um Insight violence and those are things
that are illegal in states in the
America not all not Freedom that's a
line for you no no freedom of speech is
interesting because in in the US under
the First Amendment of the Constitution
there is actually no legislation for
hate speeches we do in most Western
countries so territories different
countries differ very much and Twitter
is a global platform which creates its
own problems it has huge problems there
but not only that you've got this you
have to apply whatever the rule is
consistently across everyone and also
you have to not just make this about
celebrities or politicizing everything
because actually there are real problems
with pornography with self-harm with
lots of other things right I mean this
platform so Ben Ferguson I mean my issue
with it this was not a free speech issue
well well Ben I only come to let me know
let me put this to you Ben I mean I I
had a case on Instagram where some vile
job in this country in the UK posted a
death threat specific to me and one of
my sons on his Instagram page in public
is going through the legal process now
it's taken 16 months I have to say and
there's still been no charging decision
and I was absolutely incensed that
someone would Target one of my kids like
that with a with a genuinely horrible
death threat and I've decided to pursue
it that to me there is a line and I
think we do know where a lot of these
lines are
yeah and I agree with you and I think
that's common sense but this idea that
that Twitter should have rules like
someone's a kindergartner first grade
teacher and we're going to put you in
time out in the corner because you say
something we just don't like or you have
an opinion that we just don't like is
never going to work and I think that's
what Dorsey even understood now yes you
can have rules that you can't threaten
to kill somebody for example as you just
described I've dealt with death threats
before as well and when you deal with it
when it comes after your family it is
very personal and the fact that it takes
so long to get them taken down when you
report them but they will go after
appeal for political speech is where
there's a clear as he put it black and
white there is not a gray area here you
either have a platform that's in favor
of free speech and you can have rules
like no death threats right but this
idea that Donald Trump is banned but but
Vladimir Putin and Isis and Al Qaeda
leaders still have that yeah it tells
you that this was about targeting him
politically it was not about yeah that's
it's definitely been a bias against
conservative rights in terms of who gets
the platform and it even went to the
extent where the New York Post had their
own account on Twitter you know D
platform because they had a genuinely
true story about a laptop belonging to
the president's son it was ridiculous I
think there is too much of this be is
being made uh political football that's
absolutely true because there are real
crimes happening on social media
platforms as you said by the way your
case maybe you should quote my
precedence because actually the same
thing happened with me and I did get
someone sent to jail for exactly that
threatening to kill me and and children
Etc so you know those sorts of things
those are black and white I absolutely
agree with that but expressing dislike
or Prejudice isn't that is free speech
inciting violence and actually fueling
hate and destabilizing democracy now
those to me are also black and white and
that's what I think Trump should have
been banned for not for having views
that we don't you wouldn't necessarily
give them a life you do believe not not
for a lifetime I think you know what we
should do maybe a two-strike rule
all right final Point Ben this is this
is where you lose me you just said that
you would ban Trump so my question is
for how long and would you abandon right
before an election and use that to your
advantage would you wait for it right
before a midterm election or or a prime
minister or or any type of election in
the world and then you let people
politically know because that's
political one that they want to shut up
that's the problem if you do it the way
you're describing it it will be used to
undermine freedom and democracy okay
did he actually break the law by
inciting the rights of the capital no
yes well but there is an argument about
that some people think he did some
people think he didn't he's still going
through courts we'll find out eventually
what the conclusion is on all that but
it's a very interesting debate I don't
think there are easy answers I'm
actually glad Elon Musk is the one to
tackle them because he has a massive
brain and I think these need a massive
brain a bit like you Ben Ferguson and
then certainly like Eugene thank you
thank you both very much the two massive
brains
now what is real leadership the captain
of West Ham United Football Club Mark
Noble decided it was about cleaning out
the dressing room floor after each game
a remarkably humble act of selflessness
by a multi-millionaire star but the
whole idea was to send the right signal
to his younger players that are not
above anything and that humility matters
leadership comes in many forms but I
really like this it reminds me of the
New Zealand rugby team the All Blacks
with the most successful sporting
franchise of all time anywhere in the
world they also believe in what they
call sweeping the sheds the most
experienced and the youngest players at
the end of every game clean out the
dressing room well Mark Noble's example
Works he's actually inspired one of his
young Defenders who began doing it out
of sheer fear that his captain may find
out he hadn't watched this
there was a picture I think it was after
the Leon game where you were sweeping
the changing room
on his phone did he offer to help or not
let's clear this up the the truth is I
always do it but there was a game I
wasn't at what one was it Brentford away
I wasn't there and um I got a text
message from jono about eight o'clock at
night uh he said no I was just about to
walk out the changing room and I see
your face in my brain so I turned around
and went and swept the changing room oh
fair play I love that and if somebody
gets me a broom I'll do the studio end
of the show what I call Lydia
now China's tyrannical zero covid policy
is reaching new depths as people in
Shanghai already locked in their homes
under the world's strictest lockdowns
are now banned from getting food
deliveries and accessing certain
Hospital Services videos shared on
social media show suspected covert
patients being forcibly quarantined look
at this now the head of the World Health
Organization has issued a rare Rebecca
China saying a zero covert policy is
simply unsustainable I'm joined on my
Global public health expert Professor
Debbie Streeter Debbie lovely to talk to
you used to speak to you a lot on the
morning show great to have you on Piers
Morgan on censored this zero covid
strategy that China is still trying to
follow you were a supporter of this
early in the pandemic before vaccines
came along what changed your mind and
what do you think of what's happening in
China
yeah nice to see you again Piers I think
early on when we could see there were
numerous vaccine trials and the early
results were really promising the idea
of zero code was to buy time because
every infection averted could let
someone live into an era of vaccines
Therapeutics and actually live for years
and years to come and I think countries
like Taiwan South Korea New Zealand
recognize that have done Mass
vaccination and opened up South Korea
has no more restrictions New Zealand is
opening its borders unfortunately China
hasn't moved forward with mass
vaccination still has a substantial
fraction of elderly and vulnerable
people unvaccinated and if it opened up
the same way that other countries have
it would have 1.6 estimated million
deaths and so right now it's in a
difficult position because we know the
true exit is science it's scientific
tools but right now China just doesn't
have access to those the Chinese
government is in a very difficult
predicament which country do you think
has done the best I read that Vietnam
for example has had a really good
pandemic very low death toll very high
take up on vaccines Etc
yes I think
Asia
where they suppress they kept infection
numbers low but they didn't through do
that through daily lockdowns they knew
their economic and social performance
would really suffer under that so what
they did instead was actually watch
their borders limit importation have a
great testing and tracing system and
therefore suppress then Mass vaccinate
as soon as vaccinations became available
and then open up now back to normal and
so they've taken a wave of infections in
many cases but the damage has been
blunted because the protection we now
have through the scientific progress
over two years I was very critical of
the British government in the first
couple of ways of this pandemic I
thought they handled it really badly I
think you shared that view at the time
when you look now two years on you see
the the overall death rate now around
Europe for example and the UK hasn't
fared too badly because of the success
and speed of our vaccine program so when
you look at it in totality what would
your verdict be on the way the the UK
government has handled this
yeah I think you're exactly right peers
we have to look at pre-vaccine where we
saw in the first year a lot of live loss
unnecessarily mistakes made in delayed
testing not having any checks in terms
of people entering the country during
our first lockdown you know very delayed
lockdown in several cases but actually
when you hit 2021 the rollout was pretty
superb and Stellar I think many places
looked at Britain and said wow how did
they do that and that really credit goes
to the UK government for getting the
supply of vaccines but also the staff of
the NHS we know people were there and
working 24 hours on the weekend to get
vaccines and Jabs into arms but also the
British public the vaccination rates are
absolutely astonishing which means
people showed up they knew it was
something they could do to help us exit
this pandemic and they got not one but
two but three Jabs and that's why we're
able right now to have as much Freedom
as we do in our daily lives without the
devastation that we're seeing in other
places final question and it's a
contentious one because when people air
the theory that covert began in a lab
and not a wet Market they were sort of
taken off social media and how old and
abused and so on it's becoming a much
more popular Theory what do you think
well I think there's you know when
initially people talked about lab leak
they talked about some kind of bioweapon
I think virologists are clear this was
not designed by people this is natural
in terms of its origin where there's
more debate is when did the spillover
event happen did it happen in a wet
Market or did it happen through a lab
leak knowing that lab leaks happen all
the time in different places across the
world in the Wuhan Institute of virology
does indeed do research on coronaviruses
so I think the jury is out on this and
what you've seen is it's becoming quite
political with the who the World Health
Organization just unable to get an
independent mission in to do an audit of
that lab to actually look for reservoirs
of where could this virus be in terms of
an animal population so we just don't
know but it is an open debate and I
think there are arguments on both sides
of that debate Debbie it's great to talk
to you've done a brilliant book called
preventable it's really about how we
avoid getting ourselves into this kind
of situation again is very hard because
we never know where the next pandemic
may come from but great to talk to
you've taken a lot of flank for your
positions that you've taken but I've
always felt you followed the science
you've changed your view when facts have
changed and I think that's what
scientists should do so I thank you for
everything that you've done and good to
talk to you
you too thank you so much so my peers
uncensored next have we totally lost our
sense of humorous comedy dead we're
still alive with a new king of late
night ustv Greg Gutfeld he's alive he's
funny I think we're about to find out
after the break
no pressure Greg
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Comedy Club where no topic is off limits
and we laugh when do we all lose our
sense of humor well one person who
hasn't is comedian Ricky Gervais when
asked on Twitter yesterday what he
thought about me entering the Taliban
official spokesman he said I've lost all
respect for them it was a gag a lot of
half which didn't get the gank
why why have I lost the ability to
understand humor in a moment I'll speak
to one of the funniest men in America
great Gutfeld but first let's see him in
action
so it's 2021 and this monologue is on
the Steele dossier like a birthmark this
story never ever goes away is that my
fault no I would much prefer to do
something on Joe Biden breaking wind at
the climate Summit
that breeze was so hot Greta thundberg
asked him to stand in front of a
windmill
[Applause]
but look that fart was the only honest
thing to come out of Joe since he became
president as you know Hillary Clinton is
on her please don't forget me tour now
showing up on a late night show to crack
wise about the guy who shellacked her
like a Driftwood sculpture in 2016. yes
Trump is her meal ticket her free bird
her Stairway to Heaven she brought
Chelsea because she's also unemployed
and Bill wanted both of them out of the
house before his 5 PM shows up her
name's Crystal
well Greg Garfield tell us about Greg
brilliant to have you on Piers Morgan
uncensored I have a great time with you
in New York doing the five to show that
you're a superstar on your own shows are
the biggest show on cable in America
congratulations I want to take you back
to it thank you I'll take you back to a
quote that you said which I thought was
really pertinent to the time we live in
he said I became a conservative by being
around liberals and I became a
Libertarian by being around
conservatives you realize there's
something distinctly in common between
the two groups the left and the right
the worst part of each of them is the
moralizing and I I thought that was so
pertinent to what goes on now especially
on social media
absolutely the uh
it the one of the greatest things that
the woke has done is that they've made
humorlessness hilarious so what I was
talking about is like when you're around
the left and they they're so Earnest and
sanctimonious and yet they get nothing
done you drift away and then you get
into the conservative realm and you have
the same kind except there they might be
more religious more moralistic in a
different way and you and you move into
the libertarian world but then even you
in Libertarians you find some
humorlessness there but what wokeism has
done for all of us and has United a like
left and right and Center is they have
taught us how humorlessness is the
funniest damn thing on earth they I mean
the only reason why my show was a hit is
because of them right cancer culture
wokeism I don't have to I don't really
have to do that much work peers which is
kind of my goal in life all I gotta all
I gotta do is go on Twitter you find the
most extreme idiot which is about 10
percent right of Twitter and then let
them do the work for you they do the
heavy lifting with their you know their
Twisted mindset I mean he won't say it
was hilarious it was hilarious last
night I'll interview the official
spokesman for the Taliban and somebody
tweeted Ricky Gervais to say isn't it
disgusting that Piers Morgan's doing
this and Gervais replied I've lost all
respect for them the Taliban right of
course it's just a simple gang but
absolute Mayhem erupted because most of
Twitter just took him seriously and just
thought he was talking about you know
this was all disgusting and of course he
wasn't yeah no and it's a classic joke I
mean you could kind of see it coming
it's like you know I'd call you a dirt
bag but I don't want to insult dirt bags
it's a it's a it's so easy but the
problem with Twitter and it's it's part
of apps you know Free Speech absolutism
everybody's got to be there is that it's
given an Avenue for the humorless yeah
so they get on and they'll actually go
on and they'll see the best the funniest
part about Twitter is when people come
on and explain the jokes so I saw that
Ricky gerbase tweet the stuff that
didn't bother me was the people who
didn't get the joke it was the people
that explained the joke it was like a
David like there's like David bediel is
that his name David bediel yeah he's
British yeah he was like trying he was
like oh here's why this joke is so good
and then he goes on to explain it and
it's like oh God so you have in Twitter
you have joke explainers you have the
humorless the humorless contingent which
is probably now probably about 25 so but
it's just what you have to live with I
find that to be in my opinion more and
enjoyable than the actual legitimately
funny people I mean without wokeism and
without the humorlessness we wouldn't
have you know Tatiana McGrath well this
President this brings me to to you know
two of my favorite subjects of humor
actually which Megan and Harry who are
planning to come and hide the Queen's
Platinum Jubilee and I know you find
them a constant source of hilarities
well they don't ever intend to make us
laugh they just make us laugh
I love that her woke cartoon on Netflix
got canceled there's a group there's a
great story behind this the cartoon is
called Pearl it's about a coming of age
right which is which is a a code word
for nauseating you know self-involved
tripe so what happened is did they think
this is my favorite part so it's like
the young girls rise in social justice
and you know who you know who Megan's
cartoon is inspired by Megan she's made
the cut it's inspired by her
which is amazing and but that's that
tells you everything that in the woke
world it is not actually about helping
people it's a disguise it's a virtue
signal that helps you that makes you
look good right and there's perfect
evidence of this because they never help
anybody but themselves they don't even
change course yeah they never mean it
it's never about actually anything but
enriching themselves and making
themselves look exactly I'm preaching
one thing
I resent England for sending your
second-hand royalty to us because now we
gotta deal with this
to be fair you lost sent two women into
our royal family one of them led to an
abdication and the other one has nearly
broken up the entire monarchy so with
respect to you America you're two for
two and it's not looking good
yes I just love the fact that they
thought that they were going to be
royalty here in America so there was an
assumption that when and they were
almost there I mean they were going to
get gigs everywhere they're you know
their Netflix Hulu Apple TV everybody
was just going to give them millions and
millions and then they had to sit in a
room with them and realize my God
they're vacuous he's a nice guy
apparently but I mean just thoroughly
vacuums she leads him around on a rope
and you know and it's like that's it it
that is the kind of sitcom I want to see
I'll tell you this is a reality show the
thing I want to mention too we do a
nightly thing called the world's gone
nuts and I want to just go into this one
with you I'll clip my fingers
apologies for the American accent there
Greg but this is a such a brilliant
story it sums up the world we live in
scientists have declared that there is
sexism in the naming of parasitic worms
a team of scientists has concluded that
there were apparently uh 596 new species
of parasitic worms and of those only 111
18 honored female scientists therefore
they want an end to this
epidemiological nepotism and cronyism
and sexism in other words they want more
parasitic worms to be named after women
otherwise it's sexism
you know what I'm gonna you know this
this I'm so tired of ships being named
after women now they want our worms they
want our worms Pierce
it's like by the way by the way has
anybody talked to the worms how do the
worms feel well exactly you know oh by
the way and by the way with the head if
they had named every city worm after
women the women would have gone nuts
saying why are you calling us all out to
Paris any worms
and how does a worm feel being called a
parasite a parasite is not a nice word
why don't you call them adjunctive
livers like or uh no adjacent adjacent
survivalists because I mean parasitic
it's just so mean-spirited words have
feelings too I can talk to you uh for a
very long time I know that you you've
made yourself the biggest star on
American TV because you just laugh at
all this nonsense it is all nonsense uh
and the world has gone that's for thank
God you're here to help try and save us
Greg Gutfeld thank you I appreciate you
coming on
you got it thanks Pierce
great guy listen for me uh tomorrow
we'll be back with more but until then
stay on centered good night
foreign
Bland beige
unopinionated dross I think the British
public wants to be able to be of an
opinion want to be able to be involved
that's the great thing for me about talk
to you people will be able to get
involved I just think that we misjudged
the British public if we tell them the
whole time what they should be thinking
I am sick and tired of watching
television that tells you what you
should be thinking talks at you rather
than with you
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Zora Suleman the UK has
pledged military support for Finland and
Sweden today if they were ever to be
invaded by Russia the two countries are
considering whether to join NATO after
Putin's invasion of Ukraine police say
they believe a missing 15 year old girl
has been abducted Maddie Thomas vanished
after leaving her home in Bristol on
April the 26th and in text between
Rebecca vardy and her agent the wag was
left fuming someone tipped off a
newspaper about a story before she did
as part of the ongoing libel trial with
Colleen Rooney vardy broke down in tears
today telling the court online trolls
threatened her baby after she was
accused of leaking stories
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]